if this following footage is real I
really hope this video doesn't get taken
down let's find out we're gonna watch
new minutes on Disney Plus September 4th
eyes did see on Twitter earlier that
this rumor was going around I saw a
brief image brief image and my initial
reaction is no I really want this to
come out in theaters cuz it's the one
movie that's truly earned it for its
perseverance but then I have a bunch of
following thoughts I would make a lot of
sense if on Comic Con this Thursday or
Friday whatever I have a panel as to why
they would do this so yeah stay after
the reaction share those thoughts later
let's see looks real it's gonna be fake
what's going on everybody gets worn and
he could be fake interesting easily you
a turn of events it has been announced
that the new butan is going straight to
Disney Plus on September 4th when the
boys comes out this was real or fake and
as it stands right now it seems to be
real and there are a few key reasons why
so just lay down Magnus was aired only
in Australia and one point is that it
has never-before-seen footage in it this
footage is literally nowhere to be found
it is brand-new also
damn they're really doing it about that
streaming Plus on the TV is a real
Australian also the M at the bottom left
of the TV is the Australian rating for
Mature which is a rating that many
mutants will have and since this was
recorded by somebody simply recording
their TV it's really hard to fake
especially with the ads in it and
never-before-seen footage wait a minute
I had a question supposedly really
really big announcement coming up so
yeah exactly
somebody over in Australia made a
mistake and aired it too early right
that's my point like who would make this
mistake well just for reference
be true so Disney somehow made a mistake
and aired this when they weren't
supposed to they're not going to admit
that they made a mistake and that this
is real
Disney don't make a mistake they have a
big announcement coming up for the New
Mutants planned already to announce that
it's going straight to streaming so
everything points to this being true and
Disney has their big announcement for
the New Mutants scheduled for Thursday
so I'm expecting them to officials
really wanted you guys to stick it
through signs are pointing to it well
thanks Warren for assembling this video
look I've said countless times so
countless times I don't care if this
movie is a piece of crap or not I just
want to come on theater says I feel like
they've earned it by this point
filmmakers cast they've been patient
they keep pushing and then dessert like
it was gonna come out and then you know
certain virus circumstances prevented it
now that being said oh all the signs are
pointing to the fact that this is coming
out on streaming think about it like
yeah they are saying they're gonna have
some major announcement was gonna be
another release date no they wouldn't do
that I feel like they're gonna do this
sort of hybrid of what they did with the
Cloverfield paradox where's our side all
right we're moving it to streaming it
would make sense that they're gonna be
doing that moving it to streaming and I
think you can make a big splash if you
do that I think you can have buzz about
it I think you could have excitement I
actually think they'd make more of a
buzz if they said it's coming out this
weekend that would be the way to
galvanize people the most is like to
really drop it in as this major surprise
don't even have the anticipation factor
just it's here yeah you know it would be
very exciting and would generate a lot
more anticipation a lot more eyes on it
there's things about this it just seems
so suspicious at the same time because
this could easily be a doctor you mean
it's really the one thing that raises my
skepticism that it is doctor is the fact
that they said there's new footage in
here right at least that was that's the
main thing I was sitting there going cuz
all those interstitial blue cards with
new fonts and stuff look very basic and
I mean that Disney plus you know bumper
at the end is on so many things it
wouldn't be hard to do that and yeah the
one thing I was wondering is is there a
new footage yeah because that's the one
thing that hey I wouldn't put it past
somebody if you can leak this
successfully and make everybody believe
it's true then maybe you could hack some
footage for yourself but at the same
time that is the biggest piece of
evidence and I feel like given this time
that we're in and the fact that they
have a movie ready to go already pretty
heavily marketed and they can drop it
and perhaps maybe not lose a lot on the
theatrical roll out now you know I guess
it probably became one of those
strategic decisions yeah I would say
that most people probably want this to
happen I think most people are hoping
that they would just go to streaming it
was very few out there like us who sort
of wages waiting for it to go in the
theaters it would have been nice but hey
what are you gonna do right maybe the
drive-ins will show it yeah that's
exciting
you can't say it's exciting if you
haven't gotten to go yet I'm excited
worrying is crap well you know judging
by how engaging a movie is it all
depends I mean I did hear that there was
like contracting issues that dealt with
cuz it's all kind of confusing
everything from like HBO to Warner
Brothers to Marvel and Disney and even
when Netflix involved you'd think that
Disney made this movie so they have the
rights to it and Disney now owns Fox so
this should be a pretty simple deal to
land it gets muddied for all companies
at this point yeah because Disney I mean
they acquired the movie and I think this
was originally a part of some deal where
all the x-men stuff that was carried
over was supposed to go to HBO max and
now they've clearly probably worked that
out or who knows maybe they'll announce
some kind of simultaneous thing yeah you
know that could be an unexpected way of
diversifying even further what do you
mean by simultaneous they would put this
both on HBO max and on Disney Plus I
mean when you say it out loud it sounds
really
I'm over there I was like I don't know
as wide as possible what happened
stranger things have happened we seen
Sony and Marvel figure stuff out well
I'm also wondering though it with this
hook people into wanting to get a Disney
Plus subscription if they don't have it
already you know and I mean for a couple
hours yeah like I said sir tons of you
tell me Hamilton's going on Disney Plus
I think their subscription service went
up the amount of people that decided to
pledge for it I'm wondering with New
Mutants I don't think that have anywhere
near the same effect as Hamilton but III
wondering if there would be people who
are like yeah finally cuz I feel like
people have lost so much hope in this
movie already cuz generally I know
there's a lot of people out there who
don't who haven't passed judgment on
this yet or a waiting for it to come out
but I think there's also a lot of people
out there I would say probably the
majority have already sold themselves
that this is probably not gonna be a
good movie just because of its all the
bad things surrounding it yeah I feel
like it'll at best be fine it'll
probably be a little bit better than
some of the pessimism led you to believe
but not as good as maybe a full-on
theatrical role I might've merited yeah
and I feel like for HBO it would be a
better fit yes general but but at the
same time it's like with Disney Fox if
that makes more sense of the legality
terms or whatever and branding terms but
then again in terms of branding terms
that's very HBO to me yeah exactly
doesn't really seem keen on horror and
especially with their superhero stuff
that's coming up they're like they don't
wanna then it make it easier to just
separate the canonical crap that
constantly comes up with like oh it's
not tied to the MCU most of us know that
but I think you could run into an area
of some minor confusion for folks but I
don't I don't really know what the
marketing people at Disney worry about
when it comes to Cannon and inheriting
x-men and Deadpool and all these things
like what what how are they viewing will
help the mass audiences are gonna be
viewing this you know but then again
Spiderman readjusted pretty quick you do
with all these characters possible hey
this could be a surprise success for
them you never
I hope so I'm rooting for this movie I
really am it would be really gratifying
if it was good in some way shape or form
alright guys well what do you think
about this happening do you think it's
that's what the big announcements gonna
be you think some doofus and Australia
mess this up
how do you mess this up if this is real
how do you mess this how do you
accidentally air a commercial on
television in like a few days in advance
hey how do you do that I don't get how
you pull that off maybe this is all part
of the master plan for Disney maybe
Disney is throwing out misinformation so
that we're all like oh oh September 4th
when really that's just the Australian
release date and it will just drop this
Thursday in the States well see I mean
they'll be competing with the eyes for
the boys which are the same audience as
Disney plus I feel like the boys gonna
win that fight guys subscribe to cosmic
wonder if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects click our
notification bell again notify whenever
we got a new YouTube video well pay
hit that like button share comment
YouTube crap speaking of YouTube crap
Victoria Huntley Victoria haven't talked
to you in a while
I don't know how things have been I know
that in the UK everything with Cova is
still kind of however I hope you're
being safe I hope you and your fiance
are having a really good time of
intimacy during this time of quarantine
and such hope you guys are powering
through it just connecting and getting
to know each other on a stronger level
same goes with your family hey if you
like the New Mutants you got a whole
bunch of characters you can choose from
of who you want to cosplay as you know
magic Wolfsbane brush yeah so many
characters you can choose from
cannonballs so why don't you watch New
Mutants when it comes out and then go
yeah next year's at home Comic Con I
will have costly what are you cosplaying
as this week nothing is it just
depressing
oh that's quarantine to Missy
yeah always then done a strong one